الصين دافعت عن بعض اتهاماتي واشنطن
بانتاج الفيروس عمدا في وهان واتاهمت
واشنطن نفسها بالوقوف وراء تسريب الفيروس
بكين تشير الى تقرير نيويورك تايم في
اغسطس 2019 اغلاق مؤقت لمعهد البحوث
الطبيه للامراض المعديه التابعه للجيش
الامريكي في بورتاتريك خوفا من تسرب مياه
مستخدمه في الابحاث الى المواطنين وبان
المياه قد تتضمن مواد سامه تمثل تمثيل
خطير للجمهور او صحه الحيوان والنبات او
المنتجات الحيوانيه وايضا النباتيه بكين
اشارت لتاريخ واشنطن في الحروب البيولوجيه
بدءا من عام
1945 بعد هزيمه اليابان منحت واشنطن
الحصانه السياسيه للعسكريين اليابانيين في
الوحده 731 وحده سريه للحرب الجرثوميه في
المق حصلت واشنطن على الالاف من نتائج
الاختبارات الدقيقه للاسلحه البيولوجيه
والكيميائيه اجريت على سكان الصين خزنت
منشاه فورد داترك العسكريه في ولايه
ميرلاند التجارب اليابانيه التي تقول
الصين ان واشنطن استمرت بها لتطوير
اسلحتها البيولوجيه تضمنت تشريح الاسرى
الاحياء بتر اطرافهم لدراسه تاثير فقدان
الدم على الجسم وبعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه امنت وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
بان السوبيات نجحوا في تطوير عقار او
تقنيه تمكنهم من التحكم في عقول البشر
لتطلق واشنطن برنامج ام كي الترا للتحكم
بالعقل البشري ولادخان التحكم بالعقل
اجريت اختبارات متطرفه على المعتقلين سواء
داخل امريكا او خارج امريكا شملت
الاستخدام الاجباري للعقد قير المهلوسه
والصعق بالكهرباء والاعتداءات الجسديه
[موسيقى]